hi i'm dominic monaghan and i'm billy
boyd and today we're doing the wired
autocomplete interview
[Music]
what dominate monahan what
is dominic moynihan
doing right now i am sat with my good
friend billy boyd in the podcast studio
where we make a podcast called the
french onion in which we talk about
kind of nonsense really ready for the
next one tom go on then
what happened to dominic monahan oh this
could be anything
what happened to dominique monahan's
voice
this is probably in regards to the fact
that my voice has got significantly
deeper over the years like
unbelievably
yeah
i mean like lord of the rings my voice
wasn't necessarily deep but you wouldn't
say oh he has quite a deep voice whereas
nowadays people mention when they're
talking to me well your voice is quite
deep you always had a deep voice but you
didn't for the character of mary you've
always had a lovely resonant thank you
voices
thank you are you ready for that please
what movies has dominique monahan
watched made
been in i was in x-men you've been in
more franchise movies than anyone else i
know i think star wars yeah i think
myself and christopher lee because
christopher lee lord rings star wars
there was something else that he was in
that was exactly what
andy circus
marvel
star wars
lord of the rings
same as me so we're kind of similar i
didn't think about it too deeply i just
thought you've been in a lot but then
also i've been in small ones that people
don't know about though it was really
good pet was good what
does dominic monahan
look like now
you get three percent better every year
of your life to this point thanks bills
no worries thanks i appreciate that done
yeah oh do we do more yeah there's all
these cards we gotta keep going oh we're
doing all those cards how to
pronounce billy
boyd it's not really that difficult is
it i don't think billy boyd how would
you get it wrong
how
how tall is billy boy oh this is
controversial this is very controversial
because i will tell you right now that i
am five foot seven inches tall
no
dom says he's five foot seven but he's
taller than me so i reckon he's five
foot eight i think i'm five seven and
you're five six i'm never five six how
old is billy boyd now you'll never
believe this because of my elvish young
looks i'm 52 years old what
really
what's your secret i shaved my chest how
old was billy boyd when he was born in
lord of the rings i turned 31 on the
flight going over in new zealand i was
flying with orlando bloom it was my
birthday and we drank a bottle of
champagne in london and then when we got
to l.a because of the time difference it
was my birthday again and we drank
another bottle of champagne alcoholics
hey
how dominic monahan
how to pronounce dominic monahan the
secret here is that the g thank you
william is silent
so if you don't pronounce the g it's
monahan g the most difficult of all the
letters except for q
good point
how tall is dominic monahan without
shoes on
i'm five foot seven and i was the
tallest hobbit out of the three of us
elijah woodshawn aston and billy boyd
being just slightly smaller than me it's
true you are very tall yeah
how old is dominic moynihan i am 44
years old i know can you imagine this
you look amazing
how old was dublin
in lord durrant i was 23 when i did lord
the reign you were not was oh that's
very naive and i looked to you for
guidance and unfortunately you were
drinking a lot of champagne at the time
you got off the plane drunk from your
birthday and you just carried on
throughout the entire trailer didn't you
until today
pippin tuck why is peregrine took
called pippin it's just a nickname it's
just peregrine
that's it something something something
something pippin
why is gandra
why is gandalf mean to pippin probably
down to jealousy because of all the
magical things that pippin does during
the adventure and he is the real hero
probably that
he gets quite annoyed at pippin but he
does end up liking pippin by the end
is pippin what the real hero now they've
got to it
yes
does
pippin tuck
really sing all the hobbits sing in the
books and pippin as a character also
sings quite famously the bath song which
is i've just put two and two together i
love being in the bath more than
probably anywhere else in the world
and pippin sings the bath song pippin
took pippin took
personality pippin
took personality and made it his own
give us a board come on what pippin and
mary what happens to
pippin and mary
after lord of the rings well after the
uh
films mary and pippin made their way
back to the shire which has kind of been
sacked by sarah mann and some bad people
and they get the shire back for the
hobbits and then they spend a little bit
of time in the shire and become kind of
important people in the shire stewards
of certain lands of the shire and they
go and travel they go back to the lands
of gondor and rohan and spend some time
with pharaoh
and then also king aragorn at that point
until they both
die
what accent do mary and pippen
have marrying people have slightly
different accents mary has an accent
from the west country of england which
is kind of cornish devon like a gentle
farmer type accent and then
pippin's tattoo comes from a different
area of the shire tuckburra has a
slightly more scottish troll a sort of
northern scottish still trying to keep
it in the rural sort of site
what do
mary and pippin drink beer more than
anything else that's their drink of
choice but they're also partial to ent
draft which makes them the tallest
hobbits in the history of the shire very
very occasional margarita if they find
himself by the beach
what is the conspiracy planned by pippin
mary
and
sam
i have no idea
dan
pippin and mary oh
mary and pippin
which is which ah good question in the
movie pippin wears a scarf mary wears a
yellow
waistcoat or an america vest
did
mary and pippin
get married pippin marries someday
called diamond of long cleave and they
have lots of lots of kids one of them
called faramir who marries
saturn wise gamjee's daughter look at my
tokian knowledge does mary ever get
married
bachelor
is
frodo
related to mary and pippin he is
he is their cousin mary and pippen are
cousins
and also frodo is their cousin so yes
they're all related i think frodo is
mary's cousin once removed by marriage
not not a first cousin oh none of them
are first cousins so once removed by men
so just general cousins general cousin
copy that
what is
mary and pippin
relationship they have a lovely
relationship they like each other and
they just like to have some fun steal
some fruit some vegetables from farmer
maggots farm steal fireworks and set
them off and just have a nice time
really and then they get caught up in a
big adventure and then they become the
real heroes
throw away
what do hobbits eat hobbits offense of
bacon mushrooms tomatoes vegetables
salted pork bread
ham
chicken cheese biscuits perfect
what do hobbits
smoke hobbit smoke pipeweed now it's
quite vague in the lord the rings book
professor tolkien doesn't necessarily
talk about what
pipeweed
is but it is also commonly known
that the best pipeweed
possibly in middle earth is from the
shire and the hobbits revere it so
you've got stuff like oh toby south
farvin
that's the best the good there's the
good pipe see one of the hobbits was say
for instance running the sprints in the
olympics would they be allowed to smoke
so far thing before that no they'd be
bend
isn't that a shame
what is the home of the hobbits the
hobbits come from an area of middle
earth called the shire relatively big
there are different areas of the shire
my character marry a doc brandy buck or
mary not mary as in you know mary steen
virgin or mary jesus's mom but mary has
a merry christmas mary comes from
buckland near the brandywine bridge and
the brandywine river well done thank you
i just want to try and get that
albatross off my neck lots of people in
the united states call me mary no no
it's mary as in merry christmas
what do hobbits look like they don't
wear shoes cleanly shaven they don't
tend to care too much about their
clothes although mary the character that
i play is a little bit of a dandy so
he's kind of well-dressed for arbit
what the hobbits do in lord of the rings
sam and frodo walk
the ring to the very fires of mordor to
destroy whilst mary and pippin create
incredible distractions for the enemy
because the enemy knows that they are
looking for a halfling or a hobbit so
gandalf makes sure that pippin is seen
by sauron and then takes him to
different parts of the world so that
maybe the enemies i will get taken over
there then pippin saves the life of
different people and ultimately saves
most of the people in gondor with your
actions lighting the beacons and trying
to keep farmer alive and at the same
time mary is on the fields of battle
with the rohan army stabbing the witch
king in the knee bringing him down to
his knees so that eowyn can stab him in
the face and kill him so the hobbits do
a lot and as you can see by the end of
the movie where aragon says my friends
you bow to no one we are the real heroes
of the trilogy we also smoke a lot of
south farthing good point i think we
answered the questions quite well don't
you dom yes i think we were absolutely
fantastic i very much enjoyed revealing
some of these questions about us with me
dom monahan and him billy boyd